اهلا بكم مشاهدينا تتواصل معكم هذه
التغطيه على شاشه العربيه لهذا الزلزال
المدمر ايضا الذي ضرب اجزاء من الاراضي
التركيه وكذلك ايضا اجزاء من الاراضي
السوريه العواجل الان التي تظهر اسفل
الشاشه على العربيه اداره الكوارث التركيه
كانت قد تحدثت في وقت سابق عن اثنتين
وثلاثين هزه ارتداديه جراء الزلزال الجديد
اذا مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في تداعيات هذا
الزلزال المزدوج الذي ضرب ولايه هاتايا
تركيا وطالت اضرارهما منطقه شمال غرب
سوريا الزلزالان تسبب بها بحالتها العنكب
كبيره بين سكان المناطق التي طالها
الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا فيما دعت الامم
المتحده للدول الاعضاء الى المساهمه بشكل
اسرع في حمله المساعدات التي اطلقتها تجاه
الدولتين
ونبدا من هاتايا التركيه المنكوبه حيث
المدينه التي تحولت ليلا بعد الزلزال
الاخير الى مدينه اشباح خصوصا مع توقف
اليات فرق الانقاذ عن العمل الظلام
والسكون يخيمان على المدينه مفرد العربيه
عبد القادر خربوش رصد الوضع من المدينه
بعد ساعات من الزلزال الاخير هذه واحده من
الاف البنايات التي
تحطمت جراء زلزال القوي الذي ضرب المنطقه
الجنوبيه لتركيا مثلما تشاهدون اغراض
ومقتنيات سكان هذه الاحياء لا تزال على
حالها ولا ندري اين هم من كانوا يملاون
هذه الاحياء بالحياه الاطفال
الرجال النساء منهم من فارق الحياه ومنهم
من غادر المكان منهم من وجد نفسه الان
يلتحف السماء في خيمه باقل الامكانيات
السكون الصمت هو وحده من يسكن هذه الاحياء
الان لكن الهزات الارتداديه التي اضحت
قويه وتحولت الى زلازل هي وحدها من تكسر
هذا السكون
لتبدا هذه البنايات الايه لسقوط في اي
لحظه
بالتصدع مجددا ونسمع بين الفينه والاخرى
سقوط اجزاء من هذه البنايات ما يدفعنا الى
الرحيل باقصى سرعه من هذا المكان عبد
القادر خربوش لقناتي العربيه والحدث من
مدينه هاتاي جنوب تركيا
الله
حاضر
لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ان شاء الله
ومن اسطنبول معنا الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
طه عوده اوغلو اهلا ومرحبا بك الى هذه
النشره كنا قد تحدثنا معك في نشرات سابقه
حول عدد من
المواضيع المرتبطه بتداعيات هذا الزلزال
وايضا الزلزال سابق هذا الزلزال الذي ما
تزال تداعياته مستمره حتى الان اود ان
اعرف ما هي المتغيرات السياسيه
والاجتماعيه والانسانيه التي يمكن ان
تنبني على هذا الزلزال المدمر
يعني في البدايه لحتى هذه اللحظه تدعياتها
الزلزال الذي حصل في السادس من الشهر
الجاري لم يعني تظهر بشكل واضح اتحدث ان
كانت اقتصاديه او حتى سياسيا نتحدث اذا
حتى هذه اللحظه تم الانتهاء قبل يومين من
عمليات الانقاذ يعني في وقف عمليات
الانقاز
والانتقاد الى مرحله الثانيه او الاخرى
وهي المتعلقه بازاله الانقاد وهذا تعني
ارتفاع في اعداد الضحايا وهذه تعني ايضا
هناك ممكن ان نسمع اصوات وانتقادات ان
كانت من قبل المعارضه او حتى الشريحه من
قبل الشارع التركي الشارع التركي والمواطن
التركي انا التصوري اعتقد هو حاليا هو
يتابع تحركات الحكومه وخاصه الخطوات التي
سبقت هذه الكارثه اقصد السادس من فبراير
وحتى الاخيره ولماذا حصلت في ظل هناك
استعدادات كما تقول الحكومه التي قامت بها
السنوات الماضيه اقصد العقدين الماضيين
منذ وصول حكومه حزب العداله والتنميه يعني
بعد زلزال 99 كانت هناك الحكومه السابقه
حكومه رئيس الوزراء الراحل الجويه جاءت
حزب العداله في عام 2002 وفي تلك الفتره
هناك اتخذت استراتيجيه وهي للتعامل مع
الزلازل واستعدادات فيما يتعلق بالبنيه
التحتيه كل هذه الامور هي تكشف بعض القصور
وهذا مع اعترف به الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في اليوم الاول من حصول او وقوع
هذه الكارثه ايضا هناك اعتراف من قبل
النائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد عندما تحدث بكل
صراحه عن عدم التنظيم بمعنى ان هناك بعض
البنايات بنيات من دون تنظيم وخاصه لا
اقول في اسطنبول لكن في عدد كبير من المدن
يعني بناء عشوائي وهذا سبب بشكل كبير يعني
في
بحصول هناك
خسائر كبيره في الارواح فيما يتعلق
بالبنايات التي هي لم تكون وفق المعايير
المطلوبه خاصه ان حكومه التركيه تقريبا في
السنوات الخمس الماضيه هناك وضعت شروط
صارمه فيما يتعلق بعمليات البناء لذا انا
متصور اعتقد التداعيات هي سوف تظهر خلال
الفتره الاسابيع المقبله يعني حاليا
الرئيس التركي رجاب طيب اردوغان تحدث بان
الايام القادمه سوف تكون عمليات ازاله
الانقاذ في الاول من مارس القادم سوف تبدا
عمليات
البناء
المساكن الجديده وهناك ايضا كما تعلم هناك
تحدي اخر فيما يتعلق بتحديد لفتره الزمنيه
لمده عام في الظل هناك يعني الموارد
الاقتصاديه بالنسبه
لتركيا هناك اضيفت يعني الخزينه الدوله
هناك مليارات اخرى سوف تسحب من الخزينه في
ظل العجز الكبير الذي تمر به تركيا حاليا
في ظل هذه التحديات التي ذكرتها انت قبل
قليل تحديات سياسيه ماليه وما الى ذلك كم
ستحتاج تركيا للتعافي من تداعيات هذا
الزلزال
يعني تحدثنا من ناحيه يعني التصريحات
الصدر من قبل الحكومه التركيه هي تتحدث عن
عام وخلال عام وعد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان بتسليم المساكن لهؤلاء المتضررين
نتحدث نتحدث عن ولايه اتحدث عن احدى عشر
ولايه نتحدث عنها
خلال ساعات الاخيره الماضيه هي يعني دمرت
بالكامل اصبحت مدينه ولايه اشباح هذه
المدينه التي كانت يعني معروفه هي حلقه
وصل يعني ما بين تركيا وسوريا التجاريه
سابقا نتحدث وهي منطقه يعني هناك حركه في
التجاره لذا انا متصور اعتقد التحدي صعب
جدا خاصه ان هناك تعويض من قبل الحكومه
التركيه على مساعدات الخارجيه نعم وصلت من
عدد كبير من الدول العربيه الدول
الاسلاميه ايضا من دول دوليه هناك كما
تعلم الشهر المقبل هناك مؤتمر لالمان سوف
يعقد
لدعم تركيا
سوريا ولكن هنا السؤال الاكبر هل ستكفي
هذه المساعدات وهل هذه
المنح او التي سوف تمنح
لتركيا سوف يتم تسليمها فورا لانه نحن
نتحدث حاليا نحن عن يعني فتره زمنيه
محدوده وهناك يعني وضع صعب عشرات الالاف
لا اقول عشرات يعني الاف كبيره هي خارج
بيوتها تبحث عن ايواء هناك تم توفير بعض
الخيام بعد توفير بعض البيوت المؤقته او
المساكن المؤقته ولكن الحكومه نعم قامت
بتوفير يعني استئجار بعض الاماكن تقديم
مستحقات ماليه ولكن كل هذه الامور هي بدون
شك سوف
تكون الاصابه بالنسبه للحكومه المصقله
اقتصاديا نعم وهنا اود ان اسال الى اي مدى
يمكن ان تكون ورقه الزلزال هي مؤثره
وفعاله في الانتخابات المقبله سواء كان
لاردوغان او حتى للمعارضه
يعني تصور اعتقد يعني اعتقد حاليا هناك
هذه هي سوف
الورقه او هذه الزلزال او هذه الكارثه سوف
تكون هي مقياس ان صحه التعبير فيما يتعلق
بالخطوات التي تقوم بها الحكومه اشرتك قبل
قليل بان الشارع التركي والمواطن التركي
هو يراقب يراقب الخطوات التي سبقت هذه
الكارثه الان يتابع ما سوف تقوم بها
الحكومه الرئيس اردوغان حدد وتحدد تحدث عن
فتره زمنيه قدم كل ما لديه من اوراق ولكن
انا التصور اعتقد المعارضه هي يعني وجدت
فرصه ذهبيه لها من اجل يعني سحب البساط
تحت اقدام الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان خاصه
بان كافه استطلاعات كانت خلال الاشهر
الاخيره الماضيه كانت هي متفاوته ما بين
المعارضه والحزب الحاكم وان المعارضه كانت
لو استطاعت ان تحصل على مرشح توافقي ممكن
ان تفوز في الانتخابات المقبله ولكن الان
الحزب الحاكم هو حاليا في وضع صعب
الاقتصاد بالنسبه
للتراك هنا لتركيا مهم جدا للمواطن التركي
لا تحدث فقط يعني عن اقتصاد اتحدث عن
مباني وعن هناك ايواء واعتقد هذا هو تحدي
صعب وليس تستكون هذه الكارثه هي العنوان
الابرز في الانتخابات المقبله نعم وستعول
عليها المعارضه بحسب البعض المعارضه تعول
بشكل كبير على طريقه التعامل التي يعني
ابدتها الحكومه التركيه في
تلافي اثار وتداعيات هذا الزلزال المدمر
رهان المعارضه الان اصبح ليس على التوافق
لترشيح اسم للوقوف ضد اردوغان في
الانتخابات المقبله انما الرهان على هذا
تداعيات هذا الزلزال المدمر
صحيح نعم انا اعتقد يعني اعتقد هذه هي
ورقه كبيره بالنسبه للمعارضه التركيه يعني
التصور اعتقد الاسبوع المقبل في بدايه
الشهر القادم سوف نلاحظ ان هناك بعض
الاوراق سوف تكشفها المعارضه التركيه
وخاصه المتعلقه فيما يتعلق بالبنيان يعني
الزلزال هو لم يدمر ولكن المباني التي هي
دمرت ورفعت من اعداد الضحايا يتحدث عن
هناك مباني حديثه بنيت فيها يعني قبل عام
تتصور قبل عام بنيت وانهارت يعني فكانت
هذا اعتقد سوف تطرح هناك تساؤلات واعلن
هؤلاء المقاولين الذين حصلوا على مناقصات
ومن قبل الحكومه التركيه هل تم غض الطرف
من قبل الحكومه وهل هناك فيما يتعلق خاصه
الموضوع البناء هو مرتبط بالبلديات
والبلديات كما تعلم هي عدد منها التابع
للحكومه والبعض الاخر
اعتقد الاسابيع والايام الاخرى سوف تكون
هي ايام الحساب بصحه التعبير واعتقد ان
الساحه التي سوف تكون فيها هذه المناقشات
هي تحت قبه البرلمان التركي كيف سيغير هذا
الزلزال من المشهد السياسي في في المنطقه
بشكل عام علاقه سوريا بجيرانها علاقه
سوريا مع الدول التي لها مواقف ضدها كيف
سيؤثر هذا الزلزال في تغيير المشهد
السياسي بشكل عام
هل تسمعني
قبل يعني خلال نعم تفضل تفضل الان اسمعك
نعم الاستاذ المحلل السياسي طه عوده اوغلو
ان كنت تسمعني
على اي حال شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
الافادات وفي سوريا افاد المرصد السوري
بوقوع اربعه قتلى جراء التدافع والهلع في
حلب وطرطوس وحما بعد شعورهم بالزلزال
الجديد فيما اصيب نحو 500 شخص واكد المرصد
انهيار وتصدع بعض المباني في جنديرس
والاتارب جراء الزلزال الجديد وافادت
وسائل اعلام سوريه في منطقتي ادلب وحلب
بان بعض المباني انهارت وانقطعت الكهرباء
وخدمات الانترنت في بعض اجزاء المنطقه
واضافت ان العديد من الناس فروا من
منازلهم وتجمعوا في مناطق مفتوحه
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومن واشنطن ينضم الينا بسام بربندي
الدبلوماسي السوري السابق اهلا وسهلا بك
الى هذه النشره كيف تنظر الى تعاطي واشنطن
مع تداعيات هذا الزلزال المدمر تجاه سوريا
صباح الخير بتوقيت الشرق الاوسط الولايات
المتحده يعني اعتبرت هذه
الماساه التي جرت في تركيا وفي سوريا فرصه
لتطوير علاقتها مع التركيه واثبات لتركيا
بانها الدوله الصديقه او الشريك او جزء من
النيتو فبالتالي كان هناك رئيس الامريكي
تكلم امام مع الرئيس اردوغان وزير
الخارجيه وزير الدفاع اتكلم عن نظرائهم
الولايات المتحده ارسلت طاقم تقريبا 300
شخص للمساعده في ايجاد المفقودين ارسلت
اغاثه مواد غذائيه واغاثيه كبيره ورصدت
الى سوريا وتركيا مبلغ تقريبا 180 مليون
دولار خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين فبالتاليات
المتحده تحاول ان تستفيد سياسيه من جهه مع
الحكومه التركيه وشعبيه قول الاتراك بان
نحن اصدقاء لكم وقت الشده
الملاحظ بان هذه الكميات من الاموال هي
كميه قليله جدا بحجم الكارثه التي تجري
فيه
مليون دولار هي الى سوريا وتركيا هي مبالغ
هزيده جدا بمقارنه
بحقيقه الماساه وحقيقه ما يجري على الارض
اذا تكلمنا عن سوريا هناك في سوريا على
الاقل ما تم رصده وجود اكثر من 1400 او
مبنى سكني تم تهديمه بالمطلق هناك اربعه
عشره الف بناء او بيت
ايلين للسقوط وغير قادرين الى استيعاب
سكانهم وهو كما معروف هي منطقه فقيره فيها
كثير من اللاجئين في حوالي اكثر من اربعه
مليون لاجئ سوري يعيشون في وضع ماساوي
بشكل طبيعي من قبل الزلزال
تتكلم الولايات المتحده عن هذا المبلغ من
المال وهذا النوع من المساعدات يعني هي
اكثر العلاقات عامه من حقيقه ان الولايات
المتحده كقوه العظمى الاقتصاديه
ساهمت او تساهم في حقيقه في معالجه جديه
لمساعده هؤلاء الاشخاص وخصوصا في سوريا
اكثر من تركيا يعني تركيا دوله بنايه هي
دوله ولكن للاسف المناطق التي تضررت في
سوريا هي هي لا شيء لا يوجد فيها شيء طيب
سيد بسام يعني بناء على قراءتك لمشهد
الطاعات الامريكي مع تداعيات هذا الزلزال
من المسؤول عن تسييس هذه الازمه الانسانيه
او الكارثه الانسانيه في مصلحه من
يعني شوف بالعالم كله السياسه لا كله
مصالح الدقيقه هي مصالح لا يوجد شيء اسمه
انساني لا يوجد شيء اسمه
اشياء مثاليه الجميع يحاول الاستفاده من
اي ازمه تنشا سلبيه او ايجابيه
لتطوير او تثبيت او تقويه اوراقه للحصول
على اكبر قدر ممكن من المصالح فبالتالي
الولايات المتحده عندما تقدم لتركيا ما
قدمت له ما قدمته وضعته ضمن اطار كم
تستطيع كم نريد ان نصرف من المال حتى نقول
الاتراك باننا اصدقائكم وليس السؤال كما
تركيا او سوريا تحتاج الى مال للمساعده
الجديه في معالج هذه الازمه يعني هذه
الزاويه التي يفكر فيها الجميع بالمطلق هي
موضوع المصالح الحقيقيه ليس تسيس كل شيء
مسيس كل شيء لتحقيق المصالح فبالتالي
نقول من يقوم بماذا التركيه في من طرف
الاخر
زارها وزير خارجيه اليونان ارمينيا
اذربيجان الامريكي فالحكومه التركيه تحاول
ان تظهر او تعمل على ازهار نفسها للشعب
التركي باننا نحن لسنا معزولين عالميا
جميع دول العالم موجوده الكارثه كبيره
اكثر من طاقه الحكومه على استيعابها
فبالتالي هم محتاجون كاتراك الى اكبر عدد
ممكن من الدول ان تاتي وتقدم المساعده ولو
رمزيه للقول التركي او الاناخ بالتركي اذا
كان لديك انتخابات قريبه بان الموضوع اكبر
من حجم الحكومه التركيه على التعامل معه
في الوقت الالي الدول الغربيه تقوم بنفس
الامر ولكن بشكل معاكس السويد السويد
فلدهم من اكثر الدول اسرع الدول التي قدمت
مساعدات لتركيا واتصالات بهدف اقناع تركيا
بموافقه تركيا الانضمام
فبالتالي كل شيء او كل شيء له مصلحه ويتم
تقديم المساعدات حسب حجم هذه المصالح نعم
واشنطن تقول بانها لن تقوم بدعم يعني
النظام بشكل مباشر وانما ستعمل مع شركائها
شركائها في هذه المنطقه من اجل اعاده
الاعمار ومن اجل ايضا ايصال
المساعدات بحسب معلوماتك حتى الان حجم هذه
المساعدات حجم هذه الشراكات التي تقيمها
واشنطن مع شركائها في المنطقه
اذا يعني بما يتعلق بمناطق سيطره النظام
الولايات المتحده لا تستطيع ان تقدم
مساعدات مباشره للنظام لاسباب سياسيه
واخلاقيه وقانونيه والاهم هي المصالح ليس
لديها مصلحه بتقديم مساعده للنظام بشكل
مباشر ولكن هي ما قامت به الولايات
المتحده هي
افرغت او عطلت قوانين العقوبات
ندت سته اشهر بحيث تسمح لكل من يريد تقديم
المساعدات من الدول الجوار ان يقدم هذه
المساعدات الى النظام دون ان يكون هناك
تبعات قانونيه امريكيه على هذه المساعدات
اذا كانت هذه مساعدات مخصصه للاغاثه او
يجب ان تكون هذه المساعدات مخصصه للرئاسه
النظام الطرف اخر هو حتى اليوم لم يعلن
الحداد على السوريين مع انه عدد اشخاص
الذين استشهدوا هذه
الزلزال هما الالاف وليس في مناطق
المعارضه في دمشق في اللاذقيه في بانياس
في جبله في حاله في اغلب المدن التي هي
تحصل نظام تاثرت بالزلزال بشكل كبير جدا
ولكن النظام حتى الان مثلا هو لم يهتم
بشعبه
الحداد حتى لا تدخل بتفاصيل كثيره
فبالتالي مصلحته هو ان يستغل هذه الازمه
الانسانيه للتواصل مع اكبر قدر ممكن من
الدول العربيه والدول الاوروبيه ليقول انا
بحاجه المساعدات
والامريكان سمحوا لي او سمحوا لكم بادخال
هذه المساعدات متسته اشهر بدون اي عقوبات
املا بان يتم استفاده من هذه الازمه
الانسانيه لتطوير العلاقات السياسيه او
الدبلوماسيه وهذا هو السؤال الى اي مدى
يمكن ان يساهم هذا الزلزال او هذه الكارثه
في تغيير المشهد السياسي في المنطقه بشكل
عام
نتحدث عن سوريا او اتحدث عن سوريا تحديدا
مره اخرى مثلا في تركيا الدولتين
لتركيا هي ارمينيا
واليونان وزراء الخارجيه ومسؤولين الكبار
اتوا الى تركيا للتعبير عن تضامنهم مع
تركيا الموضوع كان سياسي وكان هناك رسائل
سياسيه متبادله في سوريا المشكله ليست
سياسيه المشكله بين نظام وشعب لا يمكن اي
دوله اخرى ان تصالح النظام بدون ان تصلح
بين النظام الشعب لوجود عشره مليون مهجر
في كل مكان بالعالم
ما يجري اليوم انه الولايات المتحده اخبرت
الدول التي تريد اقامه علاقات مع النظام
بان النظام غير قادر على اعطاء هذه الدول
اي شيء وهذه الدول هي غير قادره على اتاء
النظام اي شيء بمعنى ان هذه الدول لا
تستطيع تقديم اي مساعده ماليه لاعاده
الاعمار في سوريا
قوانين العقوبات الامريكيه وبنفس الوقت
النظام هو غير قابل على تقديم اي شيء لهذه
الدول مثل اي الاجنود اطلاق سراح
المعتقلين عوده اللاجئين او المسيحيين هو
لا يستطيع ان يقوم باي من هذه الخطوات
تجاه هذه الدول فبالتالي بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده ما يجري هو حاله من العبث السياسي
دول عربيه تنظر الولايات المتحده ان هذا
العبث السياسي هو بسبب عدم وجود سياسه
امريكيه حقيقيه باتجاه سوريا فبيقولون عدم
وجود سياسه امريكيه لا تستطيع الانتظار
الى ما لا نهايه علينا ان نحمي مصالحنا
تضمن الحد الادنى
وهذا هو هذا ما يجري اليوم يعني هو في
حاله سوريا لا يوجد حقيقه لا تستطيع ان
نتنبا بعد من هون الى ثلاثه اشهر كيف
سيكون الوضع عوده الاسدي للجامعه العربيه
لا تعني ابدا
الاموال العربيه مثلا الى سوريا لا يعني
انسحاب ايران من سوريا او على الاقل تخفيف
النفوس الايراني في سوريا لا يعني عرفت
فهي موضوع عباره عن تعويم شخص او نظام
ولكن دون تحقيق اي نتائج حقيقيه
للجمهوريه السوريه او للشعب السوري يعني
مثال دقيق على ذلك مثلا في الاردن يوجد
مليون سوري ولبنان في مليون سوري الحدود
مفتوحه هناك حاله سياسيه طبيعيه بين
النظامين مع ذلك الشعب السوري او السوري
الموجودين في الاردن والفنان لم يعدوا الى
سوريا وهذا قبل الزلزال
لاسباب امنيه لاي تقوم بنظام ليس لديهم
املاك ومشاكل كثيره هي المعروفه اليوم بعد
الزلزال لم يعد يوجد شيء من البنت التحتيه
لهؤلاء الاشخاص للعوده فبالتالي تعويم
النظام لا يعني حل المشاكل
حل المشكله هي سياسي حقيقي الدول التي
تريد التطبيع مع نظام تتغاضى عن الموضوع
الانساني السوري تنظر اليه اكثر
في منظور علينا ان لا نترك سوريا لايران
منفرد علينا ان نكون هناك في سوريا
للتواصل مع ايران ولكن يعني اذا الصعب
اليوم الحكم كيف ستكون حقيقه العلاقات بعد
شهرين او ثلاثه اشهر قد يكون هناك تواصل
سياسي كثير مع النظام ولكن هذا لا يعني
انه سيكون هناك حل او حل حلا بالموضوع
السوري الانساني الاغاثي او السياسي نعم
السيد بسام ابقى معنا سنتحول الى اسطنبول
مع الكاتب والمحلل السياسي طه عوده اوغلو
اود ان اسالك هل يعني الزمن سيسعف الحكومه
التركيه من اجل انجاز كل هذه التحديات
الماثله امامها وصولا الى الانتخابات
يعني انا التصور اعتقد تحدي صعب للغايه
والمواطن التركي والناخب التركي هو يتابع
مدى قبليه الحكومه على المضي قدما
والاسراع في تحقيق هذه الوعود وخاصه بعد
هذه الكارثه التي وصفها الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان بالاعنف والافتك منذ قرن من الان
هناك كما تعلم هناك سباق هو قبل يعني هذه
الكارثه من بين الحكومه والمعارضه من اجل
قياده تركيا خلال المرحله المقبله هناك
بعض النقاط المتعلقه في موضوع يعني تعامل
الحكومه مع ملف الكارثه التي وقعت في
السادس من الشهر الجاري واعتقد الحكم
والفصل في هذا الموضوع هو الشارع التركي
والناخب التركي الذي هو سوف يصوت في
الانتخابات القادمه
وهذا رقم كبير يعني في ظل هذه التحديات
صحيح
صحيح انا اعتقد هذا هو التحدي الاكبر يعني
حتى نحن تقريبا منذ عام ونصف من الان كنا
نتحدث دائما ان المنافس الاكبر للرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان هي ليست المعارضه هو الاقتصاد
نعم الرئيس اردوغان بعد جائحه كورونا نجح
في يعني هناك اجراء بعد التعديلات وخاصه
في فتح يعني
سياسه مختلفه او انتاج سياسه مختلفه مع
عدد كبير من دول المنطقه وعلى خروج الخصوص
الدول العربيه هو بدا السياسه صفر مشاكل
ونجحا في الاشهر الاخيره الماضيه من العام
الماضي في معالجه الاقتصاد التركي وهناك
لحظة أنا تعافي ولكن هذه الكارثه على
التصور اعتقد هي ليست بالكارسه السهله
ولكن ما نتابعهم من تصريحات الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان اذا حتى اللحظه بانه هو يثق
هناك في ثقه
وخاصه من التصريحات التي يدي بها
للمواطنين الاتراك فيما يتعلق بالوعود
التي قطعها وحدد يعني فتره زمنيه وهذا
اعتقد هذه ليس بالامر السهل والمواطن
التركي هو يتابع وينتظر
تحقيق انجازات على الارض نعم وزير خارجيه
تركيا كان اليوم قد اطلق تصريح والتصريح
لعله ياتي في سياق ما سالتك منه سابقا هذا
تصريح كان ضمن مؤتمر صحفي كان قد عقد مع
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
تحدث بشكل واضح وصريح ان تركيا لا تحتاج
الى زلازل وكوارث حتى تحسن من علاقاتها مع
دول الجوار وايضا مع دول المنطقه كيف تقرا
رساله وزير الخارجيه التركيه هذه
يعني تركيا نعم يعني تركيا هي في الفتره
الاخيره
الماضيه ان هناك من يتحدث بان يعني هذا
الكارثه هي الساهمت بشكل او بشكل ما في
تحسين علاقات تركيا مع عدد من الدول
الجوار واضرب لك مثال يعني في عام 99
زلزال يعني المدمر في تلك الفتره هو فتح
قنوات ما بين تركيا واليونان ومن ثم شاهدت
العلاقات التركيه اليونانيه صفحه جديده في
تلك الفتره ولكن يعني تركيا هي حاليا تعول
على
الادوار التي تلعبها في المنطقه على خلاف
السنوات الماضيه قبل قليل هي انتهجت سياسه
مختلفه خلال السنتين او العامين الماضيين
فيما يتعلق
بلعب دور وفتح
هناك قنوات ما عدد كبير من الدول العربيه
وازاله الخلافات مع عدد كبير منها وايضا
هناك لعبه ادوار اخرى فيما يتعل يعني
الملفات الشائكه واقصد هنا الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه دعبت الدور الوساطه نجحت في
موضوع ازمه الحبوب هذا ما يريده الوزير او
الاشاره اليه وزير الخارجيه التركي بان
تركيا هي لها يعني ادوار لعبتها خلال
الفتره الاخيره الماضيه ايضا ان تركيا
يعني هناك يشار لها بالبنان فيما يتعلق
بموضوع المساعدات يعني تركيا منذ سنوات هي
تقدم مساعدات عدد كبير من دول المنطقه
وكوارث حصلت في دول افريقيه وهي سباقه لذا
لاحظنا ان هناك عدد كبير من دول العالم 76
دوله هي تقدم المساعده وتتقدى لتركيا في
هذه الكارثه الكبيره على الرغم انه عدد من
تلك الدول لا تربطها بالعلاقات الجيده على
سبيل المثال اليونان وارمينيا مثلا نعم
وهذه الدول اود ان اسال تحديدا حبال الو
ممدوده بين تركيا وبين هذه الدول
هذه الحبال هل ستكون ممدوده الى ما بعد
هذا الزلزال ام انها مرتبطه فقط
بمواعيد وحاله انتهاء هذه الكارثه
الانسانيه
لا نتصور اعتقد سوف يتم يعني هناك استخدام
او توصيف هذه العلاقه وفي المرحله المقبله
ولاحظنا ان يعني اليونان هي التي في
الفتره الاخيره الماضيه كان هناك توتر
كبير ما بين البلدين خلال الاسابيع
والاشهر الماضيه صرعت بشكل كبير ولاحظنا
اللقاءات والتصريحات التركيه اليونانيه
على هذا الموضوع كانت هي اشاره واضحه بان
هناك علاقه سوف تكون افضل بالامس تصريح
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي مع التركي كان
واضحا بان هناك صفحه جديده في العلاقه
التركيه الامريكيه على الرغم من البرود
والفطور في العلاقه طيله السنوات او
تقريبا العامين الماضيين منذ وصول الرئيس
بيضا على الرغم ان هناك نعم جانب اخر هناك
تباين في عدد من المواقف واقصد هنا موضوع
عضويه السويد وفنلندا في هو ايضا
التصريحات التي ادلاها شاوش شغل وفيما
يتعلق بالدعم الامريكي لاكراد سوريا نعم
دعني اتحول الى الاستاذ بسام بربندي
الدبلوماسي من من واشنطن حجم هذه الكارثه
الم يكن كافيا للمجتمع الدولي وللولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد الاوروبي الم
يكن كافيه للتخلي عن
الازدواجيه في التعامل ازاء هذه الكارثه
الانسانيه
يعني شوف صعب مره اخرى الموضوع موضوع
مصالح ليس فيه انسانيه بالدرجه الاولى او
مثاليه بالتعاطي ان هناك حاله انسانيه
علينا ان نعالجها موضوع بيئه بالمصالح
يعني ما يجري في افريقيا من مجاعه خلال
القرن الماضي يفوق كثيرا كل
الزلزال الذي حصل في سوريا وتركيا كاثر
بشري كاسر معاناه بشريه ولكن المصلحه لا
تقتضي مساعده هؤلاء البشر بمساعدته الطرف
الاخر من العالم
فبالتالي هذا هذا هذا ما يحدد هذه هذا هذا
بشيء السياسيه العامه ولكن اذا اضفنا
عليها ان اغلب اقتصاديات العالم اليوم
منها كان بسبب الكورونا ثم بسبب الطماط
والاقتصادي ثم بسبب الحرب الاوكرانيه
الدول انهكت استنزفت الدول الغنيه
والعاصمه الاوروبيه
والامريكيه والولايات المتحده يعني
استهلكت واستنزفت بهذه الاربع سنين
الماضيه بحيث لم يكن لم يعد المال متوفره
الطريقه التي كانت سابقه
بيضاف اليها انه المصلحه كم مصلحه ان
تستثمر في هذه الماسات
مثلا الولايات المتحده استثمرت في الماساه
السوريه 12 مليار دولار خلال 12 سنه ولكن
في اوكرانيا هي صفه 120 مليار دولار خلال
سنه يدلك كيف كيف هي الاليه المصالح هي
التي تدير اليه المساعدات الانسانيه
وكيفيه النظر حتى الى اي ازمه تجري في اي
مكان بالعالم كما تفضل ضيفك الكريم هناك
دائما يحاول مجتمع الدولي او دول غنيه او
دول البعيده حتى اظهار نوع من التعاطف مع
الماسات من دول حتى فقيره تحاول ان ترسم
مساعدات الى تركيا او جزء من الى سوريا
ولكن بالمجمل
الدول الحقيقيه او مثلا التي لديها المال
اليه صرف المال وحجمه ومدته لها كثيرا لها
علاقه بالمصالح السياسيه او الرساله تود
ارسالها الى الطرف المتلقي
من الازمه الموجوده فيها نعم يعني كنت قد
تحدثت عن الموقف الامريكي اود الحديث عن
الموقف الاوروبي والاتحاد الاوروبي وبعض
الدول الاوروبيه الغنيه والتي تساهم بشكل
كبير في مساله تداعيات هذه الكارثه
الانسانيه على سبيل المثال المانيا كيف
تقيم هذا الوضع بشكل عام فيما يتعلق بموقف
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبعض الدول الاوروبيه
ايضا
شوف كل دول الاوروبيه لديهم يعني تركيا
كجزء من النيتو لديها كثير من الاتفاقيات
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي انها ليس عضو كامل في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكنها هي جزء لديها
كثيره من الترابط مع اليات العمل في ضمن
المؤسسات الاتحاد الاوروبي في البروكسيل
ليس مع الدوله مع منظمه الاتحاد الاوروبي
نفسها فبالتالي كان هناك تفعيله كثير من
الاليات المساعدات التي للاتحاد الاوروبي
يقوم بتقديمها للدول الاعضاء او القريبه
من الاعضاء وتركيا استفادت من هذا الامر
كنت اود اقول واقول مره اخرى بان الحجم
المساعدات له فعلا علاقه كثيره بنوع
المصلحه التي يودون الحصول عليها من هذه
الدوله
اذا فالموضوع ممكن قد يكون البعثه 100
مليون يورو مساعدات ولكن هو الطاقه
الفعليه لهذه الدوله او لهذه المكنه
الاغاثيه تتجاوز المليار دولار مليار يورو
هم لم يرسلوا الا 10% من طاقتهم الحقيقيه
بانتظار الايام القادمه بانتظار ما بعرف
شو من الجانب التركي باتجاه الاتحاد
الاوروبي
اليوم مثلا الامم المتحده عبر عدد
المنظمات الامم المتحده هم يطالبون بمبلغ
بليار دولار فوري لتقديم المساعدات
الفوريه وليس العادات ثلاثه اشهر او سته
اشهر فوريه لم يتوفر منها شيء حتى الان
نسبيا فبالتالي الاتحاد الاوروبي والمانيا
وهذه الدول تحاول من جهه اظهار تعاطفها
مساعدات فرق اغاثه خيم ولكن على المقياس
هذه الكارثه هي شيء فلا شيء لا يذكر وفي
تركيا او لسوريا نعم طيب اعود للاستاذ طه
عوده اوغلو اود السؤال هنا عن البعض وجه
سهام الانتقادات سواء كان للحكومه بعدم
التعاطي بالسرعه اللازمه لمساله معالجه
تداعيات هذه الكارثه الانسانيه والبعض
الاخر صوب سهام الانتقادات للمعارضه
التركيه على اعتبار انها قامت باستغلال
هذا هذا الظرف الانساني وهذه الكارثه
الانسانيه من اجل تحقيق نقاط سياسيه
ومكاسب سياسيه ضد الحكومه
صحيح يعني في يعني البدايه نحن نتحدث عن
كارثه كبيره لم تشدها تركيا منذ تقريبا
قرن من الزمن كان هناك الحكومه التركيه
اعترفت بالتقصير في اليوم الاول يوم
الثاني بانه هناك تقصير وان هناك بعض
الخطوات التي كانت هي ليست بالامر المطلوب
كما اراد رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان هناك كان
تساؤلات يتعلق بارسال الجيش تاخر لمده
يومين او ثلاثه
للمناطق المنكوبه ولكن هناك كما اشرت لك
يعني المواطن التركي ويتابع هنا لم يعني
هناك فقط مراقبه قبل وبعد واثناء هذه
الكارثه ولكن لاحظنا في اليوم الايام
الاولى يعني ونحن نتحدث عن عمليات انتشال
ناجين وكانت هناك اخبار مفرحه جدا خلال
الايام الاخيره الماضيه للمره الاولى الى
معجزات بعد
ساعه ان يخرج شاب او طفله فكانت هذه
الامور يعني الامور الهامه حتى هنا في
تركيا الجميع كان يتابع هذا الحدث وليس في
تلك ولكن في العالم كله كما تابعنا جميعا
خلال الايام الاخيره الماضيه ولكن السياسه
حضرت بشكل واضح واقصد فيما يتعلق بموضوع
الانتخابات وموعد انتخابات وكانت هذه هي
ممكن ازعجت الشارع التركي والمواطن التركي
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول المحلل
السياسي طه عوده اوغلو وشكرا لك ايضا من
واشنطن السيد بسام بربندي الدبلوماسي
السابق شكرا جزيلا لكم
من مدينه الريحانيه بولايه هاتاي ينضم
الينا الصحفي مصطفى النعيمي اهلا ومرحبا
بك الى هذه النشره ما هي المعلومات
المتوفره لديك حتى الان
اسماء ثمانيه في بعض المناطق ربما قد لا
تقوى على مواجهه زلزال اخر وبالتالي نتحدث
عن كوارث ربما قد تحصل ربما في مدينه
انطاكيا الكارثه الاكبر هي التي تحصل هناك
حيث ان هنالك ثلاثه ضحايا وربما قد يرتفع
الرقم وفقا للتصريحات الرسميه ان اتحدث عن
ان هنالك ما زال عالقون هنالك محاوله
انتشال جثامين ايضا من هم قضوا تحت هذا في
اي اجزاء المدينه
اتحدث عن مدينه انطاكيا طبعا التي ضربها
الزلزال هناك في اي كبير في اي اجزاء
المدينه
ليس لدي تفاصيل ولا حتى هذه اللحظه بخصوص
المنطقه التي استهدفت لكن عمليا اتحدث عن
اطراف مدينه انطاكيا نظرا ان مركز المدينه
هنالك اضرار كبيره لا اعتقد ان هنالك
مازال مدنيون او متواجدون لكن المباني
المتهالكه ربما هي احد اهم الاسباب التي
ادت الى يعني هذا الانهيار في المباني
يعني في بعض المباني كذلك ايضا حركه
الاليات الثقيله يعني كنت اتواجد في مدينه
انطاكيا مساء البارحه كان هنالك الوضوح
بشكل كبير اثناء عمليه نزع الركام او سحب
الركام كانت فرقه انقاذ تعمل بشكل كبير
وكانت تحذر من انهيار بعض المباني كذلك
ايضا يعني قبل قليل منظمه افاد يعني وجهت
رسائل الى المتواجدين في المنطقه يعني في
منطقه جنوب تركيا عموما بان لا يدخل الى
هذه المساكن التي يستقلونها خاصه الابنيه
العاليه والسبب الرئيسي يعود الى انه
هنالك رب قد يكون قد حصل اضرار في المباني
وهذه الاضرار غير ملاحظه وان المباني التي
قيمها المهندسون قبل يوم او يومين ربما قد
قد تتغير تلك التقييمات وفقا لحجم
الارتداء هزات الارتداديه المتعاقبه وهنا
اود ان اسال عن وتيره العمل في ازاله هذه
الاثار وهذا الركام باختصار لو سمحت
حتى هذه اللحظه الفرق الموجوده في مدينه
انطاكيا تعمل على ازاله الركام بشكل مستمر
وهنالك او العشرات من السيارات الشحن
المخصصه لنقل الركام ما زالت تتوافر من
والى مدينه انطاكيا وتسحب هذا الركام من
اجل افساح الطريق طريق يعني هنالك الكثير
من الطرق ما زالت مقطوعه وبالتالي عمليه
افساح المجال لهذه الاليات من اجل الدخول
والخروج كذلك ايضا هنالك بعض المسارات قد
اغلقت بشكل كامل وهي يعني وهي حيويه جدا
وحركه الاليات تتقدم بشكل اكبر في حال
مجال لهذا الطرق اشكرك صحفي مصطفى النعيمي
كنت معنا من مدينه الريحانيه بولايه هاتاي
شكرا جزيلا لك
اثار الزلزال التجميريه في تركيا في
السادس من فبراير لم تطال البنيه التحتيه
والمباني السكنيه فحسب بل دمرت ايضا
الكثير من الكنوز التاريخيه والمواقع
الاثريه ومنها اقدم مسجد في تركيا المزيد
مع زيدان زنكلو هذا هو مسجد حبيب نجار في
مدينه انطاكيا بولايه هاتاي جنوب تركيا
اقدم مسجد في تركيا ضمن حدودها الحاليه
بناه المسلمون سنه 638 ميلاديه وصمد 14
قرنا في وجه كل الظروف والكوارث التي ضربت
هذه المنطقه
لكنه تدمر بشكل كبير بفعل الزلزال الاخير
المئذنه وقبه المسجد وجزء من الفناء
الداخلي دمر السلطات التركيه اغلقت المسجد
خوفا من انهيارات جديده
كل المنطقه التاريخيه المحيطه بهذا المسجد
تعرضت لدمار كبير اسواق ومحل وفنادق تعود
لمئات السنين ضربها الزلزال بشكل عنيف
وحولها الى اثر بعد عين زيدان زنجلو من
مدينه انطاكيا هاتاي
مشاهدينا التغطيه للزلزال المزدوج الذي
ضرب انطاكيا وغرب سوريا متواصله في
النشرات القادمه اما الان ننتقل الى
مجموعه اخرى من الاخبار
وصل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى بولندا
بعد زياره مفاجاه لكيف حيث من المقرر ان
يلتقي بالرئيس البولندي اندريه دوده اليوم
الثلاثاء لمناقشه امدادك بالاسلحه وتعزيز
قوه الردع لحلف الناتو حسب بيان سابق
للبيت الابيض
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون
عن تخصيص حزمه مساعدات جديده لاوكرانيا
بقيمه 460 مليون دولار تشمل رادارات جويه
واضاف البنتاجون في بيان ان حزمه
المساعدات الجديده تهدف لتلبيه احتياجات
اوكرانيا الامنيه والدفاعيه وتتضمن
الذخيره اضافيه لمنظومته مارس
ومدافع بالاضافه الى انظمه مضاده للدبابات
ورادارات المراقبه الجويه
اعتبر الرئيس الاوكراني في ان النظام
العالمي القائم على القواعد الانسانيه
يعتمد على كيفيه سير الاحداث في اوكرانيا
وقال زيلينسكي بعد لقائه بالرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن ان شركاء اوكرانيا يدركون جيدا
الاحتياجات الدفاعيه الضروريه لانهاء
العدوان الروسي خلال هذا العام وان كل من
كل ما يتطلبه الامر هو العزم
قال وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه
انه استدعى ارفع مسؤول ايراني للتشديد على
ان المملكه المتحده لن تتسامح مع اي تهديد
لصحافيين على اراضيها واضاف كليفر لي ان
بلاده فرضت عقوبات على مسؤولين ايرانيين
من المتورطين في قمع وقتل المتظاهرين
بينهم اطفال مشددا على ان التهديدات ايران
لن تمر دون عقاب كما نشر الموقع
الالكتروني للحكومه البريطانيه تحديثا حول
اضافه ثمانيه اسماء جديده الى قائمه
عقوباتها المفروضه على ايران
في تصريح خاص للعربيه اعتبر رئيس المجلس
الرئاسي الليبي محمد المنفي ان انجاز
الانتخابات في عام 2023 يتطلب انخراط
الجميع في ترتيبات ماليه لتحديد وتوحيد
اولويات الانفاق العام معلنا ترحيبه بوضع
غطاء دستوري لانجاز هذا الاستحقاق
واستعداده للتعاون مع المؤسسات التشريعيه
للبحث في اليات بديله لتحقيق تطلعات الشعب
الليبي
الى مسقط حيث استقبل سلطان عمان هيثم بن
طارق رئيس النظام السوري بشار الاسد لدى
وصوله العاصمه العمانيه مسقط وقالت وكاله
الانباء السوريه ان الاسد التقى السلطان
هيثم في مستهل زياره عمل الى سلطنه عمان
من جهته اكد سلطان عمان مواصله دعم سوريا
لتجاوز تداعيات كارثه زلزال
يمثل غدا الثلاثاء رئيس حركه النهضه في
تونس راشد الغنوشي امام قاضي التحقيق
بالقطب القضائي لمكافحه الارهاب في قضيه
وصف رجال الامن بالطواغيت تعود تصريحات
الغنوشي الى شهر فبراير الماضي خلال حضوره
جنازه جنازه عضو مجلس شورى الحركه في
محافظه تطوين جنوبي البلاد حيث قال خلال
تابينه انه كان شجاعا لا يخشى حاكما ولا
طاغوتا ما اثار استياء واسعا لدى الراي
العام وكان قاضي التحقيق قرر نهايه شهر
ديسمبر الماضي تاجيل الاستماع الى الغنوشي
بطلب من محامي
تم استدعاء الاستاذ راشد الغنوشي رئيس حزب
حركه النهضه ورئيس البرلمان الشرعي برلمان
2014 عفوا 2019
تم استدعاءه لسماع لدى احدى الفرق الامنيه
ولكن الحقيقه
ان الملف هو ادعاء شخص نكره حقيقه لا
نعرفه
ادعاء انه عنده معلومات
لم يقدم ما يثبت تلك المعلومات
ولا الاشخاص على الاقل يبلغوه المعلومات
هذيك ولا دليلها
قام بمهمته هو شخص وظيفي قام بمهمته
قدم معطيات غالطه
ولكن المهم حول لا شيء حول لا شيء
حول لا شيء حول لا انا نقول لك لا حول لا
شيء لا فسد مالي لا ارهاب جنوبهم القضايا
الموجودين في بلادنا هذا المعلومات اللي
عنا
نعم
وغدا سناؤكد لكم ذلك ايضا
اذا مشاهدينا بهذا انتهت هذه التغطيه التي
استمرت لساعات من العربيه الى لقاء